tell me about your your relationship you
are
so I'm like uh I'm like a I guess
dominatrix kind of and
like I've known baby for like less than
six months
you know I like humiliate him and like
treat him like a baby and do like
whatever his
that's what he's into so that's that's
what kind of relationship is it is a
sexual relationship is it a is not at
all a sexual relationship I'm completely
disgusted by him to be completely
upfront like and he knows this like
that's what turns him on is the fact
that I'm completely grossed out by him
so he wants to just like act like a baby
so I don't know what his real private
life is like I have no idea I met him
online he doesn't speak when we hang out
at all he makes like baby noises and
then like
he communicates your texts so I got like
a text message like you know we do can
we set up a session he called it and
then like you've never you've never
interacted in person where you're
speaking like two adults I've never
heard like his voice like whatsoever I
have no clue what it sounds like